Speaker 1: Why don't we talk to?
Oh, I don't know. I mean, maybe.
Let's try Marcos from Florida.
Marcos, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: You hear me.
Speaker 1: You sound like
you're underwater. We can hear you,
but you sound like you're underwater.
Speaker 4: I'm sorry, okay. I don't know if it's
better now, but it is. I just want to say I'm a
Speaker 2: fan and
Speaker 4: I enjoy your
Speaker 2: show. I was going to
Speaker 3: ask you about Trump's talking about
the deep state. Yeah. And you're like blaming
the deep state for everything. That's wrong.
But it was during his presidency, so
does that mean he was not in charge?
Is he saying he was just a puppet? Right?
Speaker 1: No, you're making a very good point,
which is, I mean, listen. So first of all,
what Marcos is referring to is that during
an interview with Mark Levin this
Speaker 2: week, Trump blamed the
Speaker 1: deep state for trying to remove
him from office through the FBI investigation.
Deep state is just another
shadow government conspiracy that
someone else is really in control.
Speaker 5: Sometimes it's the Jews
Speaker 1: could be Bill Gates could be the
Bilderberg is the Illuminati, the trilateral
commission. Whatever it is, it's fascinating for
you to frame it in these terms, Marcos, because
if indeed the deep state was in charge at the
time, it means Trump really was not in charge. And
at the same time, if Trump was in charge, then why
Speaker 2: is it that he
Speaker 1: wasn't able to take control of
the deep state and who is in the deep state
because it was his government, of
Speaker 2: course, and it's all
Speaker 1: completely incoherent and
you're absolutely right to point that out.
Speaker 2: Norman, Marcus, we're losing you.
Speaker 1: You're going underwater more so I'm
going to let you go, it's quite a connection.
But I do appreciate you calling in today and
it was really, really great speaking with
you. That's going to do it for calls today,
folks. We will take calls again and next Tuesday
we have the David Pakman Show Viewer Town Hall
at 6:00 p.m. Eastern Time, during which we will
be wide opening the discord lines and anybody who
wants to can call in. Let's take a quick break
and we will keep going with the Friday show